PETE: So, what about scalability in your architecture?
How do you handle that and what are some considerations
that you're looking at in terms of making
sure your application architecture is set
that you can scale, because you guys are,
you're not huge right now, right?
But obviously the goal is to processing, I'm
sure hundreds of thousands are more accost
than you are and you keep scaling that up.
VIDA: Right, So, it's also naturally partitioned
right now, where our Simple DB store wanted
to be global.
So, we always want all of our users to be
on just one database, to be readily available
to us.
On the other hand, since we're set up with
retailers, we could actually partition, every
retailer's data can actually be completely
separated and partitioned from the other.
So, we can serve traffic for specific clients
on specific servers with a different database.
So, I'm never worried about one particular
database having to handle a humungous load.
For our consumer data, I didn't build simple
DB so I don't know how it works but there's
always things you can do for a consumer, you
could separate our their data and modulo it
according to certain keys, put all your users
at that end with this number on this particular
user data.
So, there's still ways to partition the user
data.
My guess is that Simple DB probably already
does that and kind of hides that from the
developer without having to figure that out
by serving it automatically on separate servers
without you noticing and labeling the whole
thing as just one big service.
PETE: So, you anticipate pushing Simple DB
as far as you possibly can, you're just going
to keep throwing users at it and if it starts
to cry and scream then you'll reconsider.
But right now, you think that's probably going
to suit your scale.
VIDA: I hope so.
I would definitely go with the key value store
rather than a SQL store.
I think that SQL has a lot of overhead because
you need to process queries, where you need
to query across it and build indexes across
it and all the other stuff.
And if you want scalability just being able
to store data in different places and partition
it out makes a lot of sense.
I mean at Google we didn't use SQL at all
in our back end servers anyways for speech
recognition or even in our web server.
So, just not really used to thinking of SQL
as the automatic database choice as I think
most of the industry does.
PETE: What about the breath of social data
that you have at your disposal from, say,
a Facebook API, one of the challenges there
is that, that data is always changing, right?
And Facebook is basically changing the schema
behind their API and adding fields and deleting
fields and probably merging stuff and whatnot,
they're known to do that right?
VIDA: Right.
PETE: Does that give you a lot of headaches
and problems?
VIDA: No, because we didn't choose to store
the social data in a SQL store.
But it is true, I think you wanted to have,
we could originally define a user profile
and assume that their DB certain fields, we'd
always have to be updating schema and things
like that.
So, Simple DB is really nice because it doesn't
assume a strict user schema.
You can still label parts of it but you don't
have to strictly label it that way and predefine
it.
PETE: Okay.
VIDA: So, that allows us to be really flexible.
PETE: So, those are really great compliment
to each other.
The social data you're getting from a “not
always what you'd expect” Facebook API and
the schema-less format of Simple DB.
VIDA: Yeah.